all right we'll call this nap time
so you all take a nap I'll just lay up
here
Let's see we got we got three minutes
all right folks how many
uh so I'm American so if I say American
things I'm sorry uh who's first NDC
okay that's a good number of hands uh
this is my third in DC for some reason
they keep inviting me I don't know why
uh and this is the first time on the big
stage so I'm a little anxious about this
so you all would do me a favor by kind
of pumping me up like
go Kevin I mean or don't it's all right
yep so you all just had the the rice I
bet and you're all getting that carb low
right now you want to take take that nap
all right I know how it is
everyone got all silent sorry
uh any fellow Americans in here
no awesome
excellent no countrymen
all right so uh anyone not from the UK
all right all right have better anyone
not from Europe
okay
I I like to oh I saw a ham where are you
from
I'm sorry
South Africa excellent that is quite how
long is your flight
couple hours
12 hours okay
a couple hours you know I'm American we
don't know geography at all on this side
of the world so
all right that is quite all anyone
farther than South Africa that's not a
speaker is probably a good way to put it
yes sir where are you from
New Zealand
I'm sorry that is quite the haul
I was chatting with another gentleman it
was from um uh uh I don't know same
continent but
he was talking about how bad his flight
was and I'm over here complaining about
my six hour flight overnight and
when you go home
when do you go home
oh you live here oh so no so you missed
the whole point of my discussion all
right so if you're going home on
Saturday we could I was trying to make
but excellent
all right I think I'm mad time
all right 140 so welcome everyone the uh
make sure you're in the right room I had
to double check at least five times to
make sure I was in the right room so the
tactics for building background Services
in.net uh I'm Kevin Griffin and I I've
done this talk a couple times in front
of user groups just kind of warming up
figuring out how I wanted it to flow in
different ways I always had trouble with
the start and because the beginning of a
talk is kind of important I have to get
your energy up I'm after lunch and it
this is kind of a boring topic and like
all things said this is a boring Topic
in terms of software development but I
have talked to enough people and I've
done this talk enough times where the
boring topics are most useful to people
so I'm hoping at the end of this talk
each and every one of you
as you're putting green in the Box on
the way out
you say I have gotten something out of
this that's that's useful uh so how do
you start a talk like this I actually
got this idea from my pastor which is a
weird thing uh I was in church and I
have a slide for this there we go uh not
my pastor just stock photo
uh he didn't like me taking his photo
uh and I had this idea because he was up
there and I go to one of these uh more
not a traditional church it's one of
these like we call them strip mall
churches I don't know if that's a thing
over here but it's a church startup and
it's mostly entertainment and then
coming out and they they talk about you
know all the church stuff
and I see the the pastor up there and
he's doing his thing I'm like I don't
know what the pastor does
outside of
the performance and
I say this as a person that's behind the
scenes I'm running a camera for the
church I'm helping with sound at the
church but there are people running
around doing all the work to make this
worship happen and the pastor just has
to show up and present
now all things said and if he ever
watches this I'm sorry he does a lot
more than that but it seems like from an
audience perspective he just gets up and
does the work
all the background work is being done by
the people behind the scenes and have
you ever been to a concert have you ever
seen a political person speaking or just
a a
like a life coach like a Tony Robbins I
don't know if there's a appropriate
analogy over here someone getting up and
they're doing the presentation but all
the work is done being done behind the
scenes
take any concert you've ever been to the
any major concert you've ever been to
uh the folks up playing the instruments
singing the songs they're not the ones
running the cables they're not the ones
tuning in the guitars they're not the
ones switching things out those are all
being done asynchronously behind the
scenes by background services
so I had this thought this Epiphany
during a worship service I went wow this
church environment is kind of like how
we should be building applications and
your application is no different than uh
any of the examples I just mentioned
your UI is the presenter it's it's out
there talking to the world giving them
information and taking back feedback
from them but it should not do anything
important and this is kind of my opinion
your front end your UI should be
relatively dumb what it should be good
at is marshaling or delegating those
tasks to other services in the
background and let them go do the work
so this is obviously a UI that I did not
design because it looks really good
and
I want to use as an example of a real
story of a application I walked into a
long long time ago where we had
something very similar to this not as
pretty but I want to focus on this pay
now button at the bottom and our app was
not what you would call
good
we had technical debt and we loved it
but every little bit of technical debt
we could add uh we we put in there so I
came onto this application and the
workflow worked something like this I'm
leaving some of the tidbits out but you
pay now we go into the back end we
create an order we go we check the
inventory we charge the credit card
because you got to take the money and
then finally we send the email saying
hey you're all good to go and then we
send back the success the confirmation
there's a fundamental flaw with this
plan
email server isn't reliable all the time
anyone who sends transactional email
into your system knows email services
are not reliable they go down
uh ours would go down every now and then
right after you charged the credit card
like a hard charge and it would send
back an error to the front end saying
hey there was a problem processing your
order but we had processed their order
we just didn't send them email
and it was one of those problems we were
like you know we should fix this but we
didn't actually ever fix a problem I
ended up leaving the project way before
those problems ever got fixed
and you're out there probably laughing
going that's not how people write
applications anymore but you know we're
all friends here right
right
you know these applications out there
run every single day these are the
applications that ask you not to press
the back button
because they're doing this stuff in the
background they don't want to double
charge you because they totally would
they'll charge you
all right so all things says hi I'm
Kevin
hey yep there we go audience
participation is amazing a little bit
about me I am a Microsoft MVP I love
working in asp.net core building
applications in Azure and anything web
development independent Consulting
working with a couple fairly large
companies in the U.S and I would love to
talk to you anytime after this session
if you have questions
here's my contact information uh
including Mastodon like are we still
doing that
maybe I don't know okay never mind uh
you can talk to me afterwards I would
love to chat more
uh I have a course if on signalr then
I'm
you know trying to get you all to buy
but because I love NDC I'm giving it to
you all for free uh so for the next five
days you can use the code NDC London
2023 I'll drop this in the slack in case
you don't want to snapshot it and I
would love for you to go get a copy and
give me some of your feedback don't sign
up unless you're giving me five stars
that's the rule and like you're not
allowed to leave unless you give me a
green slip
all right our agenda for today I have a
limited time my goal is to put some
tools in your toolbox we all have these
mental toolboxes of ways we know how to
solve problems and we've all been in
that case where we're in a meeting like
I know exactly how to solve that problem
because I only know one way to solve
that problem
but with something like background
Services there are
multiple ways to solve the problem it's
all cases specific
um we've all used the term well how do
you do X Y and Z well it depends we've
all said it here I'm going to give you
the various cases of it depends and some
of them won't apply to you at all some
of them you probably already know about
others I'm hopefully teaching you
something new
let's go back to our problem of the pay
now button that just is awful
how should we do this a little bit
better first the pay now button still
you click it we still want to create our
order uh in the U.S we have a problem
with Amazon I'm not sure if that's a
problem over here as well we just like
buying stuff on Amazon and if you've
ever ordered anything from Amazon
you click the the buy now button and it
doesn't give you back a
confirmation that your order has been
charged and shipped it gives you just
speca confirmation that your order has
been received and that's all we really
wanted to do in our situation we want to
create the order and confirm with the
user that it's been received they can go
about their day
but in the background we want to start a
workflow we want to start a process that
will eventually take the system to a
point where we are charging the credit
card and we are shipping the product
uh so the three steps still apply
they're just being done asynchronously
of the pay now button
check inventory straightforward do we
actually have in stock what we said we
did yes no
charge their credit card or other form
of payment
there's been a number of times I have
gone on to an Amazon hit pay now
thought I was using a good credit card
and then a couple minutes later I get an
email from Amazon saying your payments
method was bad and you need to fix it
before we will continue with your order
if you don't do anything they cancel it
so this is a step up in the asynchronous
process let's charge your credit card if
we can't we try to fix the problem and
then we jump back into the workflow
and then finally when everything's said
and done we ship the product we send the
email and you start watching the
tracking codes every five minutes
so we're talking about background tasks
background Services there are two types
I'm going to kind of lump into this talk
there's on demand where we have
processes that need to happen now
I hit the pay now button I need to go
check inventory I need to start that
workflow
if you're pressing a button to send an
email well we we don't want to wait till
later to send the email let's get a
workflow going to send the email
uh I do all kinds of on-demand services
so emails are great one
checking Payment Processing
uh web hook so uh the most popular one
we use is stripe and we get web hooks
for subscription updates so if a payment
fails in the future we get a web hook
saying the payment failed we send a
notification to our customer via that
web hook that's something that we want
to do on demand basically
uh in any processing but what I kind of
mean by this is we have data that's
coming in all the time as data is put
into our database we set up asynchronous
processes that go and clean that data up
a lot of cases we have to go look up
geographical information
and this is not stuff that needs to
happen immediately but it needs to
happen eventually
we also have scheduled or reoccurring
tasks and these are things that happen
on some sort of schedule like a Cron
uh our most common one is probably
hourly but we have some that we do
weekly or monthly and they're just
boring things that have to happen on a
schedule generally these are reports or
any sort of resource cleanup one of the
first ones I ever wrote was uh we had a
directory where it was just filling up
with with log files and we never cleaned
it up until we ran out of hard drive
space so we wrote a job that would go
clean it up every 30 days
simple things that aren't really
glamorous they're really boring but
they're critical to production
applications
when you're building a background
Services couple conservations you should
make because this this is the it depends
uh first where are you going to host it
uh if you're local anyone out there
building
let's say like thick applications
winforms WPF was it Maui now
okay I was waiting for the hands I'm
like do you all just not want to admit
it I'm sorry uh so I'm assuming the rest
of y'all are web Developers
now as
come on folks raise your hands you're a
web developer be proud of it all right
cool uh so if you're the few people that
are building real applications on the
desktop uh you you really don't have
that many cases
you can do a Windows service which are
actually really cool they're being
they're coming back into style you could
do this work inside your existing Client
app which isn't really good unless the
client app's running if you shut it down
it's not going to do much
uh the rest of us who are web Developers
uh if I'm running an aspi course app I
can actually run it inside the process
so my my web app is also performing my
background services
if you're deploying the cloud now I'm
very partial to Azure and Azure
functions and Azure logic apps I love
that stuff but if you're over on AWS you
have similar services that are available
to you as well
we need to consider resiliency in our
background Services because
I I have a couple projects that we have
inherited
where they were
uh
their basically console applications
that ran forever
and if they threw an exception and
wasn't handled it would crash the app so
you get that call saying oh the
Checker's down okay well someone has to
log into the server they have to restart
the service and then everything comes
back up until it crashes again
and it crashes infrequently enough where
no one wanted to solve the problem so no
one really did but when it comes to
background Services we need to be aware
of resiliency how
how do we handle a case where a task
fails
if I'm trying to send email and my email
service is down
what do I do next well in most cases you
wait 30 seconds you can try again if I
try to charge a credit card and I don't
get a success back from the credit card
company or the payment processor do I
try again after a period of time
that's up to you
uh what happens if the server crashes so
my console app crashes and someone has
to log into the server in order to fix
it that's not the best way to go
um we need we need to consider what are
the ways to fix that problem
all right I'd like to show you a couple
tactics we're going to run through them
I'm actually not going to do any Live
code I'm just going to show you example
example example we're going to move
fairly quick
um first I want to talk about net hosted
Services I'm making a good assumption
most of you are probably on anything
beyond dot net three one
now if you're out there going we're
still on.net three
five
from the previous generation I'm sorry
this talk is not for you
uh but I want to talk about.net hosted
services this was added into.net core
and it's a really cool concept where uh
your.net host your application can
manage background services for you on
your behalf and you can have one you can
have 15. you just create them using
their uh implementation and the Don has
will automatically manage them for you
and I say.net host
when we originally got this feature we
all kind of thought it was just for
asp.net core but it's not we can use
this in.net console applications we
could use this in Windows Services we
can use it wherever we want
and it's a pretty straightforward
implementation you create a class
and you can Implement from background
service
or you can also Implement from I hosted
service but it's a little bit more
effort background service does more for
you underneath the scenes
and you just write code inside of your
execute async method that you're given
to do the work
and when that method returns
whether on purpose or not the background
service is done it has done all of its
work
so this just runs continuously in the
background for the lifetime of your
application and what's really cool is
because it's inside the facade of a.net
core.net application you get all the
benefits of.net so if you want to use
dependency injection for your logger for
any of your own dependencies you just
inject them and net will take care of
the rest for you
to run it it's as easy as going into
your application host
so this is for a console application but
it's very similar if you were doing
asp.core application and in your
services you say add hosted service tell
it what service you're adding and it
takes care of the rest for you
so I thought it would be fun that we
build a Windows service
so I'm going to jump into some sample
code real fast
actually let me show you this first
so everything I'm showing you is based
off of this package
who's ever built a Windows service
before
not with top shelf
oh you see the hands go down oh yeah so
top shelf was really great
um back in the older.net days because it
actually it helped you uh if you were
building a Windows service from scratch
it was a pain in the butt because
there's all this Unwritten undocumented
or hidden documentation for writing a
Windows service you have to handle the
slash S command or the slash whatever
command and they all do different things
within windows but you don't know that
the first time you're writing a Windows
service and back then we didn't have
stack Overflow we didn't have chat gbt
to tell us how to do all this work it
just was this hidden knowledge that was
passed down amongst the Elder Developers
now you just go install a package
uh I'm not going to say that so Windows
services and you add one literally one
line of code use Windows service and you
can set some configuration it will take
care of all the crud for you
automatically
I love this and I wish I had this now
top shelf did a lot of this for you it
was just slightly harder but it was
easier than the alternative
now we can jump into my demo
so I have a demo just kind of outlining
and all this code is going to be
available for you afterwards where we
take the example I have on screen
this is a console application basically
where we're creating our host
we're adding a Windows service
and then we're adding a hosted service
so the windows service part is not
actually going to matter yet but the
hosted service part is
if we go into my cleanup folder service
and this is a very straightforward
example of cleaning up resources
every what I have 15 seconds I want to
go check a folder a temp folder a temp
folder not an important folder made that
mistake once
uh we're we're going to go through and
we're just going to see if there are any
files in there if there are any files
and any file is older than five seconds
I don't remember why I added that that's
past Kevin's problem
uh if we see any file older than that
we're going to delete it so it's
automatically going to clean up itself
the cleanest folder on the hard drive
we'll go up to the command prompt and
I'm gonna bump that up a little bit more
for y'all uh we're just going to say.net
run
give it a second
uh so this is starting a host for me
is telling me that it is checking the
folder seat colon
temp which I will go to real fast
and as you can see there is nothing
inside of this folder
I'm going to add
a file so we'll add a word file
and let's see if I can move the stuff
around
now remember it has to be older in five
seconds so not enough time had passed
we're going to wait
in 15 seconds for it to go and
it should
you ever notice like 15 seconds is an
eternity when you're standing in front
of a group of people uh all right it
deleted the file yay Kevin deleted a
file no do not applaud for that uh no
I I would take it any day of the week I
did not deserve it then
all right that's not deserving let's go
ahead and shut this down
let's shut down our file I'm going to go
into my notes
so part of the repository is this
awesome readme file where I have all the
commands for you we're going to publish
a release version of this executable
let that go for a moment while that goes
I'm going to open up my services section
of
windows
I'm going to scroll down
and I just want to show you there's
nothing in here called tactics
because that's the name of the service
with my build
I'm going to copy another command
and I'm going to open up a command
prompt
just because Powershell doesn't do this
particular command very well and this
command is sccreates so we're talking to
the services layer inside of Windows
we're asking it to create a Windows
service for us and we're telling it the
executable for that Windows service
hit okay create service success
if we go back into our services
refresh
scroll up we see tactic Windows Services
uh
I'm going to start it
then I all right running awesome
we're going to go back into this folder
now I don't have any log here it because
I didn't set it up to to log to the
event log or anything we're going to go
to C sharp
temp we're going to create a file
we'll do we'll do publisher this time
just so you don't think I'm faking it
and then we have to play the waning game
I have uh I've played with these delays
15 times and every time I knocked up it
deleted
now I can clap
yeah I wrote a background service I
wrote a background well I didn't really
write the background service I showed
you the background service I had written
earlier but trust me it took 10 minutes
and chat gbt did like 50 of it
uh
so a background service is running it's
doing the work it's inside of a hosted
service which dotnet just gives to me
and everything is great
now
jump back in the sides
all right so a couple pros and cons I
want to talk about pros and cons of all
these different ways to go uh first pro
you just saw is really easy to build so
if you need something that's running on
a server and it's a server you have
control over think about a Windows
service because
Windows is automatically going to take
care of the lifecycle for you if the
service is running Windows will make
sure it continues running or you'll get
the proper notifications if it it needs
to shut down for any reason
uh it is limited to a single server so
if you're running a farm you have to
install it on every single machine in
your farm which is probably not ideal
I always like this is better for an
application you're shipping out so if
someone's running your thick clients
maybe have a Windows service that goes
along with it uh
now notice I was doing time to work
every couple seconds we were doing a
check if I had anything I needed to do
on demand slightly harder to do here I
would have to have some sort of message
service bus or message queue
to help the service do the work so
probably not ideal in those cases
uh and then individual tasks I didn't
have a try catch around all the work
being done so if it had thrown an
exception for any point so maybe it
didn't have access to a file it was
locked by another process it would throw
an exception crash my background service
but my
entire process would still keep running
so that's kind of a that's a bad thing
so I'm not protecting myself against
myself
I get this question often what about
Linux isn't.net this whole
cross-platform awesome you know piece of
code now yes there's system D support
which I've only played with a little bit
but the same idea drop this in instead
of saying use Windows Services you say
use system D and it does all the work
for you
uh I haven't tested it yet I'm working
on that but you all should test it for
me
okay let's take our concept of I hosted
service.net hosted services and let's
move over to ASP on my core which I'm
assuming a lot of you in here might be
using
you probably have seen this before this
is the non-startup way the minimal API
way of building applications now but
it's the same idea we're injecting a
service
uh same service cleanup temp folder
or whatever you call it you inject it in
the same way as you would any other
service in your application
and then I have the other stuff that
goes along with the Espionage core uh
yeah that's all so I don't need to
re-explain how the temp folder cleanup
works I can just jump into
the example where I have a slightly
altered version of of the service it's
still implementing
background service
and a slightly different delay the
biggest difference is I'm asking the
operating system for a temp folder just
because of Rights if I were to deploy
this to another system I might not have
access to the C drive I might only have
access to certain folders so if you look
at this example I'm asking specifically
for a temp path which
we spit out to the console so we'll find
it here in a moment
uh in program CS
it's almost identical not quite but the
biggest thing that is identical is that
we're injecting the hosted service
and we also have a Hello World mapping
because why not
if I go to command prompt
say.net run
now this is going to tell me where my
temp folder is which is in my user
folder
let's go open a
see there's nothing in there
I'm going to drop in another file
and for some reason I'm also spinning
out the date time I don't know why I did
that but if we wait a couple seconds I
think this was 15 seconds it's going to
delete that file automatically
yay they found the file delete the file
okay okay but this time it's inside the
context of an asp.net core application
so at the same time I can open a browser
and I get hello world
so I have all the normal things a web
app does but in the background it's
doing resource checks it's doing
whatever scheduled things I needed to do
which is kind of cool and this is what
we've done on a lot of our different
apps where we'll set up a hosted service
that listens to a message queue and if
we see something come into the message
queue then the web app needs to respond
to we
we use that as a way to get messages
into the aspl and the core app to notify
others I told you I have a signalr
course on this
yeah I have a whole section where I talk
about this specific con uh context
where we get a notification from outside
the application and we send
notifications down to everyone who needs
to know about it we use hosted service
Now Kevin what if
oh pros and cons
uh biggest Pro again very easy to build
um literally took the same file with a
couple alterations and dropped it into a
new application had the functionality
because it's running inside your
existing aspm and core infrastructure
you can just deploy this so it doesn't
matter if you're running on Azure your
own IIs or if you're running on AWS or
Rackspace or you name it
if you're deploying your asp.net core
app you're deploying your services
they start automatically when the app
starts up that's a pro and they're still
the problem where if they crash you have
to you have to deal with that we also
have the problem with scheduling if I
need something to run on a more precise
schedule I have to write that in myself
but here in a moment we're going to look
at what may be a better way of solving
that problem
again if the process crashes the entire
background task stops and awesome it
doesn't crash your pro your whole
process but your background service has
stopped working
there are ways to restart a background
service afterwards they're just very
cryptic and not well documented
quartz I so I want to talk
specifically about the problem of
scheduling things and quartz is really
good about this particular problem uh
who's never heard of quartz before
all right that's actually the number of
hands I was expecting
I thought now I I thought everyone had
heard of Courts and I was the last
person to the game I'm not you are
uh so quartz is a
High Precision scheduling system that's
that's a nice way of putting it where
you create jobs
and jobs are just work being done
they're they're technically the same as
background services or I hosted services
and then you set up triggers for those
jobs so a trigger might be a cron every
30 seconds every three weeks every year
and or it could be on demand I need this
job to run now I need this job to run
now
quartz is a little bit more code to get
it up and running it took me more than
five minutes to create this sample but
here's the general idea on the left we
are creating a new job and every job is
keyed with a magic string saying this is
the job we want to run
and then we point it to a class
that implements the job
then we set up a trigger in my case it's
going to be a crons and well every 30
seconds I want to go run this particular
task and
you know there's also stuff with
durability so you if you want to make
sure it runs every 30 seconds no matter
what you can program in say
well what if the entire process crashes
and then comes back up well let's pick
up where we left off is there any cron
jobs that we missed it will
automatically pick up from where it left
off
uh then we set up the server and it all
runs
this is what a job looks like you have
to implement ijob instead of I hosted
service or background service and you
have to implement their execute method
now with a little bit of work so that's
why I have the packages on the right
side you can set up asp.net or net
dependency injection so you inject all
your dependencies
if you don't do that you you have to do
a lot of extra work so they've created
the tools for you they just take a
little bit of implementation
but you set all this up you get a very
similar demo to what we had before
now here's the code you just saw we're
creating our quartz instance we're
adding our server
and here is the full job where we create
our temp path and then every
couple seconds we're checking that path
looking to see if there are any files if
there are any files we're going to
delete them
and this time I don't have a delay
because I'm letting courts take care of
the scheduling for me it's automatically
going to decide oh it's been 30 seconds
actually for the demo it's 15 seconds
but every 15 seconds we're going to run
this job
let's go
back into our code we'll say that had
run
quartz is a little chatty in the logs so
we'll give it that
uh important things it is
oh I have to wait for it to run one time
but it's going to be the same temp
directory in a moment
there it goes
all right so it's looking actually it's
looking a slightly different location
let's copy that
oh no it's not
we're going to create a file
Rich text again
up so it was too fast for me I created
the file it deleted it instantly uh do
you all really need to see it again yes
you do
Excel I learned the hard way don't
create a new access file because it
actually tries to open access and no one
wants to go on access all right there it
goes again 15 seconds all right maybe
it's five seconds out it passes delete
the file except this time it's happening
on
a more recurring schedule because quartz
is controlling
the job for me on my behalf
and what I really like about quartz is
uh is very precise so I can set up the
schedules I can set up the the
reoccurrence any way I want to and
quartz takes care of it for me I don't
like writing those systems
uh
I'm not showing you an example of it but
you can also do one-off or on demand
jobs because jobs and triggers are
separate entities in in courts I can
create as many jobs as I want and I can
fire them on demand or
I can fire them on the schedule
it's also possible to set up a separate
job server which I like a lot as your
application gets bigger because
you don't want your web app doing all
this work you don't want your WPF or
winforms client doing all this work you
might want to step a separate job server
and just publish the jobs and
your court server Picks Them Up and does
it elsewhere so that way you're not
accidentally
I've learned this the hard way I've
accidentally overwhelmed a service I was
hosting my web app and it's like why is
the web app going slow well it's because
we're running background services at the
same time inside the web app
you don't want that to happen so we run
a separate job server
this is the biggest con is a lot it
locks you into courts so if you ever
feel like you need to move on to
something else afterwards I've done this
multiple times in my career I start on
one thing and then I change my mind I
find a new hammer and my nails change at
the same time
uh
I don't like walking into court because
it doesn't easily move from application
application or tactics to tactic at
least I hosted service I can go from
console app Windows service to asp.net
core app if it follows the the
prescription
if you use quartz you have to use ijob
you have to do it their way which I
don't actually think is best
and there's a lot of work you 've tied
into the.net ecosystem so if you want to
use di
with.net you have to do the extra work
to make that happen
so awesome but is a tactic that you
could use next Hang Fire
I put Hang Fire in because I have a
special place in my heart for Hang Fire
who uses Hang Fire
who loves Hang Fire yeah Hang Fire is
really cool until
I'm going to get to the until the moment
Hang Fire basically takes the great
parts of everything else that we've
talked about and gives you a UI for it
which who doesn't like a good UI like
there are so many people out there who
just hate command line terminal stuff
and they see a UI and they get they get
giddy um this one's even got charts and
grabs that are just useless
but Hang Fire is really cool because you
don't have to tie into their way of
thinking
like with quartz I had to implement I
job with I hosted service I had to
implement I hosted service or background
service with Hang Fire I just write my
own class which I might already have
sitting around doing its thing I could
take my existing class with my method
names my list of parameters my complex
objects and I could just go in and sorry
for the code I can just say well I'm
going to add a job and you're going to
use my class and Hang Fire you're going
to execute my method
and it also supports their the
reoccurring tasks the crons so which is
the example here recurring job every 30
seconds we're going to do something
but I can also schedule future work to
be done
so don't do it right now but do it in 30
seconds from now I could schedule a job
for later to be done and I'm going to
show you another example here in the
code
but the best part of all is you get the
fancy UI if you set up the mapping and
it ties into all the ASP on that stuff
so you don't
even have to worry about your own
authentication you just tell Hank fire
use my asp.net core authentication that
I already have and it's like okay cool
it does all the work for you
so let's jump into the demo
let's turn that off
all right so Hang Fire looks this is
actually the thing I hate about the
minimal API like file scoped everything
it looks like a lot of code but it's
really not we're just building on what
we already have
so first thing I'm doing is I'm adding
Hang Fire uh
a thing you have to do with Hang Fire is
you have to have a backing service by
default they use SQL Server SQL Server
is the worst way to host these jobs
don't ask me how I know that
if we have time I will tell you the
story of how I dedos myself
now you're like hurry up Kevin I want to
hear that story all right so I have
hangfire it's going to
run a job every 30 seconds temp clean up
the temp folder
we set up some Hang Fire stuff I also
have two methods because it's an asp.9
core app right I can write methods that
do work uh first one is generate now so
I figured what if I have a service
that's cleaning up the files why can't I
create a service that creates the files
for me and creates a lot of them
so I have two of them the first one
generates the files now and then the
second one generates them later which
we'll get into that
I'm going to run this code oh this show
you the
slightly different same Concepts
Implement is in a slightly different way
this is my own class no implementations
we're going to get the temp folder
we're going to see if there are any
files in there if there are we're going
to delete them yay
go back out to the command line we'll
say dot add run
foreign
because I gave it a SQL server
connection string it's automatically
connecting to SQL Server it's creating
tables in its own schema for managing
Hang Fire and it's going to give me my
instance
now it's sitting here and it's running
I'm going to open up a browser
I still have hello world and this should
be a different port yep different port
so you know it's the this
different I'm going to go to slash Hang
Fire and zoom out
there we go you get this fancy UI if
you're using Hang Fire and you turn it
on you don't have to use the UI
the UI does give you a couple of cool
things it tells you
current jobs you have queued either
enqueued to happen next things that are
scheduled to happen later things
currently in process are currently
processing
it shows you your six successes your
failures it's like your mother right
it's like ah
you're so close but yet so far you
failed uh you could delete jobs if you
need to
um I've actually never put anything into
a waiting so we'll just skip that
if a job fails it's going to give you
the opportunity to retry it
it's like well you failed this time but
we're going to give you 10 more chances
and if you fail that 10th time we're
just going to pretend you're no good and
we're going to throw you away
so you can watch the retries here we can
track our reoccurring jobs so here's the
reoccurring job I set up
it's tell me the cron instance like how
often is this going to run and what file
what namespace method is it going to run
and how often is it going to run
so this is running every couple seconds
if I go into the jobs folder we can see
my successes are many it's just because
it's running it's waiting for me to do
some work
and
oh actually I'm sorry some of these are
from when I was testing the demo earlier
so disregard anything five hours ago
let's go ahead and generate some jobs
so I'm going to
go into my temp folder so this one's in
temp job for some reason
let's put our files side by side
and we'll say generate now
all right adrenal a whole bunch of files
now and they're gone
let's go see what
Hang Fire did
well Hang Fire
this is our generate call
and it's telling me I activated
an instance of so here's how you read it
read the logs it's also what I love
about hangfire we activated an instance
of cleanup temp job
our temp folder job and we executed the
generate method on it
and
it shows you the logs of all that
working when was the job created when
was it added to the queue to be done
when did it start processing how long
did it process for when did it succeed
or when did it fail
if it failed when was it retried if it
retried did this succeed or fail and
keeps doing all that until it fails for
the 10th time or it succeeds
if you want to maybe
I want to try this again I'm debugging
an issue and I know it occurs in this
particular instance I can say re-queue
it gets added back to the the list let
me
files get added back I didn't actually
go run the command in the browser I just
re-ran the job
and we'll wait a moment and it'll clean
up again
I wish there was a way I could time that
where I would say again and it would
never mind
all right now this is really smart and
I'm going to schedule another one say
schedule what I call it later
this shows you a scheduled job that's
going to occur in a few seconds
and how well does it show yeah you can
see scheduled is blue for one if we wait
a couple seconds it'll turn
it'll turn zero and it'll execute the
job
in a few seconds
all right
so it's going to run
oh so
I had a race condition on myself I
generated and cleaned it up within like
a millisecond of each other okay so it
did the job it generated
then it cleaned up
here's the one key thing I want to show
you let's go into this and I'm going to
add a property
that doesn't do anything but I just want
to show it to you
um
name
and let's see where's my generator so
this won't compile now but we're going
to generate a name with a good
and we'll do two string
I'm going past that name into
to generate
oh no let me put in generate generates
better
and then we'll add a log because you
should log everywhere hey oh I have
copilot on so
who's using Copilot
see every hand should be up right now is
really cool and it's really cool it's
hilarious when it's not
all right so I'm going to log out the
name I'm going to add
see co-pilot doesn't know what I want
there we go all right we're going to
spit that give it out and what I'm
really trying to show you here is I want
to pass parameters
so I'm going to pass it go into both
those cases we'll go out to our
terminal we'll restart the service
and we are going to generate now
again
I'm going to generate
you can see here I have a slightly
different log and it's telling me what
parameters are being passed
now there's a couple cool things here
I'm sending a string but I could very
well sand an integer I could send a
decimal I could send a complex object if
I pass in my own complex object a
hangfire automatically serializes that
the Json stores it and makes sure that
all the data I intend to send
gets sent along
I'm not going to go through the demo
right now just trust me on that you can
send very complex objects and hangfire
takes care of all of it for you
the other thing you can do so go into
the pros and cons for for Hang Fire
again you have very precise scheduling
and timing making sure you have things
that run exactly when you need them to
run give or take a couple milliseconds
if I need to do jobs on demand Hang Fire
makes it extremely easy because I'm just
telling the hangfire hey go do this work
for me please
everything I run is strongly typed so
I'm using my own code my own methods
their parameters I don't have to abide
by the man's rule of implement this and
have the methods I expect you to have I
can use all my own stuff and there's no
magic strings I think magic strings are
the worst and I have absolutely no magic
strings here
having a UI is super useful because I
don't know how many times someone has
come to me saying Kevin the job for
whatever failed I go in the Hang Fire go
find the failed job and it's like oh
that's right we change the configuration
object and we didn't make the change
throughout the board
so I can just look at the error and I
can see the error over and over and over
again and then I can go make the fix and
everything starts working
uh you do have to use SQL Server as your
default backing store I don't have the
time to explain how I DDOS myself so
feel free to grab me outside afterwards
if you want to use a better data store
like redis
my redis guy's not in here it's
paywalled so you have to pay for a hang
prior Hang Fire Pro in order to get the
the reddest stuff but it's it's kind of
worth it but there are also ways you can
hack the SQL Server instance to not DDOS
yourself
you can run a separate job server I do
that
it's a pain in the butt and I don't
recommend it for anyone because there's
the the problem with running a separate
job service is because we have strongly
typed jobs and when you make a a code
change in one place you have to deploy
it in two places and it causes a bit of
an issue
now we run Hang Fire in production on
several projects I'm involved in
and the the nice thing about it is it
does everything we need to do but we are
starting to hit these walls where Hang
Fire is not enough for us specifically
around deployment having the separate
job server
we are moving on to another service that
does the same thing I think is the best
way possible and that's Azure functions
uh I used to be that guy
that sat sat in my chair and went
serverless is just other people's
servers
I have converted I drank the Kool-Aid it
is good it is it's like a like a grapey
fruit punch flavor it is really good I
love serverless
I love Azure functions
I like Lambda I haven't done a lot of
Lambda but it's there it's all in the
same problem just differently
I love this stuff
uh here's an example of an Azure
function Azure function works on the
same concept as everything else that
we've talked about
we have triggers
and we have work being done
so a trigger here in this case is a
timer trigger so I'm using my own class
I'm just decorating the method in a
certain way
I'm telling the Azure functions here's a
method that I want you to know as timer
get RSS feed I want you to run every 30
seconds and we do the work inside of the
dots
now this is great for timers so I could
have as many timers throughout the
entire app as I want but you have a lot
of different triggers that you can use
you're not doing just timer triggers now
or on demands like a web hook triggers
you have a you have a cookbook you can
even write your own
so in our application we use a lot of
blob storage triggers
because we're on Azure we use what else
we use Q storage all the time because we
cues are the most efficient way for us
to really send data around our different
workflows we're too cheap for service
bus so we don't use service bus that's
different story timers all over the
place
but there's a multitude of different
triggers that you can use but the whole
idea is that we want to move our code
our background Services out of our
systems and we want to put them in a
more I love the term Cloud scale now I
didn't used to love the term Cloud scale
but Cloud scale is effectively what we
want
now I'm not going to go through this
whole whole demo you know what yes I do
I have enough time
so here's the demo it's setting up a
sorry it's setting up a timer trigger to
run every 30 seconds to go off to my
website get to RSS feed and it drops it
into a blob storage that's all it does
so a couple little things with this
example is first it's C sharp you could
also write these in JavaScript
it's a lot more Hassle and there's two
or three other languages functions are
supported on as well
but we're going to take the code and
we're going to Output it to a blob store
which I just gave it the location in my
attribute
and this is going to run every 30
seconds
now to show you I haven't done this
already
to zoom there's no folder in here it's
going to be called output
so zoom out let's start our Azure
function
all right so it's running in about 30
seconds it's going to show you the job
running to go off to my website grab the
RSS feed bring it back drop into a
folder
so we use timers all over the place for
for different sort of cleanup jobs uh we
use them for report jobs I have one that
runs every day at nine o'clock Pacific
time in the US and it goes off to a
database get some data brings it back
creates a report
uh all right so we just ran
so now if I go back into blob storage
zoom in refresh nope
all right we have our output file and
there's my RSS feed which I'm not going
to show you
but it's there and it's doing the work
now I could also I use Azure functions
for web hooks so all the stripe stuff I
talked about a little bit earlier this
these are services that
we kind of rely on we we expect them to
do
uh we need to know when these
notifications come in we put those in
Azure functions because the Azure
functions are always running if our
services are being overwhelmed at the
time
we the the functions just create more
instances they they scale up naturally
so we very rarely ever miss a message
because of
our fault
now I'm trying to wrap this up a big Pro
of azure functions or serverless in
general I I use the term Azure function
just because I love Azure functions uh
precise scheduling and timing and we're
talking up to the milliseconds it runs
when you expect it to it'll run once
even if you have 20 servers all running
in Azure functions
if it fails for any reason it's
automatically going to try again until
you tell it or up to five times
we have a lot of options for triggers
not just hooks or on demand or timers we
can do blob storage queue storage you
can write your own
glad scale I love Cloud scale there is
nothing more satisfying than dumping a
queue with
half a million entities
and watching Azure just go nuts on it
where before we had a our own little
console Cron job that would just for
each over everything that we had in in
um in the queue and that worked it was
slow but when you divide that across 20
Services 20 servers it knocks it out in
no time at all
so and it costs three cents at the end
of the month when we're all done I love
classical and I'm a convert to to all
the serverless stuff
um our tasks are independently resilient
so if one thing crashes it doesn't
affect anything else
if I don't even have to really try catch
around any of my services if they fail
they might automatically retry
themselves like timers or I get a proper
I can get a proper notification that
they did fail
uh big con well for Azure functions you
have to be on Azure to use Azure
functions but if you're on AWS you have
Lambda and there are other providers out
there that provide serverless aspects
all right so big conclusion
I hope I taught you something that's
kind of what it comes down to I hope I
put some tools into your toolbox and I
hope that if you aren't already doing
some work in the background or at least
saving calls for later
I hope you take some of these Concepts
back to your jobs and maybe for some
change everything should be in the
background in my opinion except very
critical UI
items that need to be done but with all
that said I am happy to stick around to
answer any questions you have if not I
will see you all at the pub have a good
night
foreign